et c'est mon dieu
pourquoi
hier soir
que nous
lorsque
alors françoise s'est pas trop déçu par
le résultat des élections de dimanche
dernier
si bien sûr c'est toujours décevant de
constater que la démagogie et la
fourberie fonctionne mieux que les gens
fonctionnent mais à françois mitterrand
karim embarqué pour elle c'était pour
barbe combat pour chirac aux 182 voter
chirac avant l'été dit ça s'est fait
dans libération dix jours après les
élections
oui c'est possible et ici je pense que
c'est mauvais pour la france aux
élections de mi temps je ne connais pas
assez la politique et économie pour pour
savoir ce que parce que si c'est bon si
c'est mauvais j'aurais préféré
effectivement que les kills chirac ou
parce qu'elle fait ses preuves et
qu'elle avait l'air particulièrement
dynamique
j'ai pas du tout envie de retrouver la
clique qu'on alimente 80 comment tu
expliques que la plupart des artistes
sont au premier rang
francine question du célibat julien
clerc et des conditions socio culturel
moi c'est pas une un jeu très mauvais je
pense pas que ça
comme ça comment ça tu penses que ça
peut être créer du temps déjà des trucs
comme ça que c'est toi qui me demande
d'aller le dire des choses bien au
contraire de ce qu on pense alors
mitterrand en 83 84 il avait un mauvais
passage
astral avait des ennuis dans son trou tu
regardes pas tu l'as pas fait son thème
astral pour les connaissances thème
astral je sais que sa dominante et je
sais que c'est une dominante qui donne
les des champions de navigation en eaux
troubles
ouais ah bon les castings les scorpions
il ya surtout un pluton très très fort
un bond de liens et elle est plutôt bien
ce sont des gens vraiment
donc moi personnellement je me méfie et
qu'elle a eu la curiosité de regarder
pour les 7 ans qui viennent cela se
passait mais je veux dire par rapport à
lui lui les laminer chiant justement
qu'il va tout à fait à l'encontre de ces
tendances il n'est sûr que c'est un
destinée c'est le brouiller les pistes
et cela n'est dans plusieurs directions
longtemps là il faut vraiment qu'ils
prennent une direction claire et précise
des personnalités socialistes en vue
c'est michel repères que les échéances
les plus importantes et lui michel
rocard contrairement à mitterrand est
capable géré sa personnalité le porte
avoir une ligne droite et d'une
suffisance en quelques mots
l'uci
l'achat
attention
g
alors il ya 20 ans 68 arrêter la scène
vingt ans plus tard tu sais pas oui
maintenant parce que c'est pas prémédité
l'arrêt de fans des verts avec des
lacets ne s'était pas vraiment prêt
visiter c'est que c'était un arrêt
temporaire puis finalement c'est un vrai
disque grand bien dans la colère parce
que tu as 44 ans pas plus chanter c'est
pas ça c'est que je pense qu'on en a
assez de se retrouver dans l'analyse
émission de télévision avec les mêmes
gens quand je passe ma vie ma première
fois sa démission comme celle ci mais
c'est vrai que finalement sur le plan de
de la réalisation des chansons il n'y a
pas eu beaucoup de progrès de fait jeudi
un même je dirais même que celle inverse
il ya toujours des exceptions j'ai
participé l'a récemment à une émission
confrères je vais des lumières
magnifiques mais dans l'ensemble c'est
plutôt moins bien qu'avant alors vos
enfants disent ils de retomber dans ce
stress parce que c'est toujours très
très stressant ce show très difficile de
se retrouver comme ça devant une caméra
à défendre une petite chanson
souhaitez-vous qui n'est que ce que ce
qu'elle est c'est fait sienne une petite
chanson et en plus de savoir que les
gens qui sont en train de nous
vous filmez montrez moi quand ça parle
pas du tout ça va j'ai remarqué alors
tout va mettre fin et puis quoi c'est
devenu une corvée pour toi c'est ça de
l'enregistrer mais cornet les yogis sans
parler des plateaux même le studio ces
deux studios c'est quand même beaucoup
moins excitant pour moi maintenant que
ça l'était dans les années 70 par
exemple et musiciens et les deux
machines
voilà il ya cela il faut qui fait que
bon c'est vrai que c'est moins
intéressant c'est vrai qu'il ya des
problèmes qui se posent je sais que pour
le dernier disque que j'ai fait qu'il
sera maintenant j'ai eu des problèmes de
justesse la première fois de ma vie
alors je pensais d'abord que c'était
parce que j'étais fatigué ensuite je me
suis dit si tu es peut-être parce que
les instruments acoustiques laissez pas
accorder exactement la même façon que
j'ai vraiment synthétique
il ya de toute façon un petit peu des
deux et la promo se formèrent votre
sinon c'est soit ça m'ennuie pas
vraiment de retrouver avec des
journalistes par exemple de et de
papoter avec frein parce que quelquefois
il vous pose des questions que vous vous
posez ça que vous vous seriez pas posée
qui vous oblige à réfléchir à certaines
choses dans ce sens c'est toujours
intéressant mais ce qui m'ennuie
je peux pas faire de pourcentage avait
bien une fois sur bon en fait les sept
plus c'est peut-être moi je ne joue pas
c'est quand je lis et quand je n'ai leur
cycle ou disons très exactement ce que
tu vois là on est très souvent trahie on
est d'ailleurs où au moins trahi par les
étrangers que fait parler français
quasiment tu seras 33 qui s'appelle
décalage qu'il a fait avec qui je
laissais avec un enfin avec beaucoup de
gens en priorité avec un un ami qui
s'appelle jean noël chalet à composer 5
des musiques et avec lequel j'avais déjà
enregistré vip une chanson qui
s'appelait il ya deux ans et qui a
coproduit donc cet album on l'a
enregistré avec des anglais enfin il est
musicien mais un policier un
coproducteur dans 33 tôt il ya deux
chansons il ya une qui s'appelle miss
kiss in his le mx team il ya un jeune
matteo qui s'appelle je suis de trop
est-ce que possible qu'est-ce que ça
traduit des problèmes avec dutronc c'est
vraiment parce que c'est un jeu qui me
qui me plaisait et puis qui collait bien
à la mélodie
quand enfin à partir du moment où ces
dix-sept chansons
forcément ils traduisent en partie mais
en partie seulement une partie donc
votre votre réalité personnelle parce
que vous vivez personnellement mais
bon il ya toujours comment dire aussi
dans cette réalité d'une part
d'imaginaire quelquefois des situations
dont je parle ce sont des situations que
j'ai pu s'imaginer que je sais qu
vraiment mais cela correspond à des
émotions vrai que ça va bien avec lui et
je vois c'est toujours annoncé que ça va
salut à toi comment il va depuis qu'il a
arrêté de boire bien il n'a jamais été
aussi séduisant fin plus tôt que ouais
aussi séduisant comme toujours il était
le plus séduisant possible il salue
casse pas le moral trop je sais pas
c'est quelqu'un qui parle pas beaucoup
donc c'est difficile un petit peu de
savoir ce qui se passe dans sa tête je
pense que c'est très difficile
certainement mais il ya des jours où on
sent que c'est difficile surtout je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui entre
autres problèmes à celui de manquer un
peu d'ambition sur les difficultés à se
mobiliser alors s'intéresser
lui-même d'abord et à partir du moment
où il ya plus stimulant que l'alcool ça
va être encore plus démotivant une
manière générale les choses c'est
bizarre tous les deux parce que lui
quand même bon quand il faisait des
chansons c'est que c'est génial
ensuite il a fait du cinéma c'était
encore mieux spielberg a dit qu'il
voulait le lavoir comme acteur affiché
pendant la passion qui ne l'a pas voulu
apprendre l'anglais puisse la salle est
un peu comme ça parce qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup d'ambitions quand j'ai quand
j'ai connu
enfin il plaisanté avec ça ne s'était
pas vraiment une plaisanterie il voulait
que j'engage comme jardinier est souvent
j'ai pensé que c'est quelqu'un qui
aurait été pour moi plus heureux s'il
avait une activité qui avait consisté
justement à s'occuper de plantes
d'animaux puisque je pense quand il
était plus jeune il avait pensé être
vétérinaire
non mais enfin c'est quelqu'un qui est
plus près finalement de des plantes
l'hexagone de la nature et des animaux
que des gens soient c'est un peu pareil
finalement j'ai hâte a toujours du
succès est allé mais comme jacques neau
comme dao qui quittent idolâtre mais
j'admets kitty le lad et finalement tu
t'arrêtes tu sais pas qu'est-ce que vous
avez tous les deux vous laisser aller
comme ça la tendance est la même
moi je me laisse pas les litiges à ne
pas travailler on n arrête de faire des
deals et depuis je suis pas on est en 88
ça fait huit ans que j'ai je travaille
comme une folle je suis tout en doublant
délai jamais de disponibilité parce que
en même temps ces huit ans que je
travaillais pour une conne station radio
j'écris
2 et c'est bon c'est pas d'accord ce qui
vous fait ça ah non non mais mais de
toute façon je crois pas qu'on puisse
mélanger les champs je pense que jacques
de toute façon va continuer à faire des
disques en tout cas au moins il y en a
un qui est prévu puisque là il est parti
en corse pour composer et puis je pense
qu'il a fait un spectacle aussi alors
que moi toute la partie représentait la
partie de représentation pour jacques
n'est pas n'est pas un problème c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a vraiment le trac les
mois pour moi c'est un problème parce
que j'ai vraiment le trac et dont je
trouve que 20 entre axa se fige j'arrête
tout
m
oui
j
mais aussi
non
je suis heureux
je suis
mon chien